Traductor: José Luis Penalva Marín
Revisor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Cuando Nicolás Bourbaki solicitó entrar
a la Sociedad Americana de Matemáticas
en los años 50,
ya era uno de los matemáticos
más influyentes de su época.
Había publicado artículos
en revistas internacionales
y sus libros de texto
eran lectura obligatoria.
Aún así, su solicitud fue firmemente
rechazada por una sencilla razón:
Nicolás Bourbaki no existía.
Dos décadas antes,
las matemáticas estaban patas arriba.
Muchos matemáticos de prestigio
murieron en la Primera Guerra Mundial,
y el campo de las matemáticas
se fragmentó.
Cada rama usaba una metodología diferente
para conseguir sus propios objetivos.
Y la falta de un lenguaje matemático común
dificultaba la divulgación
y la expansión de sus trabajos.
En 1934, un grupo de matemáticos franceses
dijeron: “¡Hasta aquí hemos llegado!”.
Cuando estudiaban en la prestigiosa
“École normale supérieure”,
les pareció que el libro de la clase
de cálculo estaba tan desarticulado
que decidieron escribir
uno nuevo y mejorado.
El pequeño grupo no tardó en ampliarse,
y conforme crecía el proyecto,
también lo hacía su ambición.
El resultado fue el
“Éléments de mathématique”,
un tratado con el que buscaban
crear un marco lógico
que unificara las distintas ramas
de las matemáticas.
El texto comenzaba
con un conjunto de axiomas simples:
leyes e hipótesis que usaron
para construir el argumento.
Después, los autores desarrollaron
teoremas cada vez más complejos
que correspondían con trabajos realizados
en todo el campo de las matemáticas.
Pero para revelar realmente
una base común,
el grupo debía identificar
reglas coherentes
que se pudieran aplicar
en multitud de problemas.
Para conseguirlo, redefinieron claramente
algunos de los objetos matemáticos
más importantes,
entre los que se incluye la función.
Es razonable ver a las funciones
como máquinas
que aceptan entradas y producen salidas,
pero si las viéramos
como un puente entre dos grupos,
podríamos empezar a afirmar
sus relaciones lógicas.
Por ejemplo, piensa en un grupo de números
y un grupo de letras.
Podríamos definir una función
en la que cada entrada numérica
correspondiera con
una misma salida alfabética
aunque esto no establecería
una relación particularmente interesante.
Una alternativa sería definir una función
en la que cada número
correspondiera con una letra diferente.
Esta segunda función
establece una relación lógica
en la que al procesar una entrada
se genera el resultado correspondiente
al elemento de salida asociado.
El grupo comenzó a definir funciones según
cómo asociaban elementos entre dominios.
Si la salida de la función provenía
de una única entrada,
la denominaban inyectiva.
Si todas las salidas podían asociarse
a al menos una entrada,
era una función sobreyectiva.
Y en las funciones biyectivas,
cada elemento tenía
una correspondencia perfecta, uno a uno.
Esto permitía a los matemáticos establecer
una lógica que pudiera ser traducida
entre los dominios de las funciones
de manera bidireccional.
Su enfoque sistemático
a principios abstractos
contrastaba enormemente
con la creencia popular
de que las matemáticas
eran una ciencia intuitiva,
y una sobredependencia en la lógica
limitaba la creatividad.
Pero esta banda de eruditos rebeldes
ignoraron con mucho gusto
la sabiduría convencional.
Estaban revolucionando
el campo de las matemáticas
y querían poner la guinda al pastel
con su mayor hazaña hasta el momento.
Decidieron publicar
"Éléments de mathématique"
y todos sus siguientes trabajos
bajo un seudónimo colectivo:
Nicolás Bourbaki.
En las dos siguientes décadas,
sus publicaciones se convirtieron
en estándares de referencia.
Y los miembros del grupo se tomaron
la broma tan en serio como su trabajo.
El matemático imaginario afirmaba ser
un genio ruso y ermitaño
que solo se reuniría
con sus selectos colaboradores.
Enviaban telegramas
en nombre de Bourbaki,
anunciaron la boda de su hija
e insultaban públicamente a cualquiera
que pusiera en duda su existencia.
En 1968, cuando ya no podían
seguir con el engaño,
el grupo acabó con la broma
de la única manera posible:
Imprimiendo el obituario de Bourbaki,
plagado de dobles sentidos matemáticos.
A pesar de su supuesta muerte,
el grupo con el nombre de Bourbaki
aún existe hoy en día.
Y aunque no esté asociado
a ningún descubrimiento importante,
la influencia de Bourbaki
llega hasta la investigación actual.
Y la importancia moderna
de las pruebas formales
le debe mucho a su rigurosa metodología.
Nicolás Bourbaki pudo ser imaginario,
pero su legado es muy real.